очевидно що голова Верховної Ради не
директор колгоспу а робота депутатів
Верховної Ради вона не оцінюється за
критеріями екселівських табличок І
знаєте там як надої молока у корови Хто
скільки там Чого надаїв І так далі Це
абсолютно іншеі критерії професійності
відповідальності і таке інше І тому ми
би дуже хотіли щоби Ну от Голова
Верховної Ради перестав перешкоджати
діяльності народних депутатів і
щонайменше 10 представників нашої
фракції будуть звертатися до судових
органів щодо протиправних дій як
керівництва парламенту яке блокує наші
міжнародні відрядження так і постанови
уряду